[Musique]
à me mêler de la vie
si tous quand est astucieux
le plus sérieux à jouer il s'est mis
debout doit obéir à un ami
[Musique]
comment ce qui m'a alors dit dos
aujourd'hui c'est toi qui amène le jury
aujourd'hui j'ai préparé un petit tour
de cartes que je t'ai fait l'autre jour
dans la forêt que tu as beaucoup aimé
alors je vais le refaire pour nos amis
voilà vous allez prendre un jeu de
cartes avec 4 valent les quatre volets
seront les quatre voleurs voilà les
valets bon puis là nous aurons la maison
ça c'est la maison et vous prenez d'un
autre côté le roi qui sera le
commissaire de police
alors c'est extrêmement simple vous
allez voir comment j'ai fait je prends
les quatre valait que je vais mettre sur
la maison 4 valait que nous mettons
immédiatement sur la maison bien
maintenant je prends la maison voilà
attention le premier voleur s'en va au
fond on va le mettre ou non pour tous là
en bas c'est à dire disons au rez de
chaussée le second voleur que voici va
s'en aller lui allait carrément à la
cave on le met carrément en dessous
bon le troisième on va le mettre si vous
le voulez bien vers le deuxième vers le
deuxième étage là et puis enfin je vais
te combien là c'est le quatrième c'est à
dire oui c'est le dernier
wissant va au troisième étage allez hop
voilà ils rentrent au troisième étage
bien maintenant que la maison est
envahie par les quatre voleurs le
propriétaire a eu le temps hop d'aller
chercher le commissaire de police le
commissaire de police arrive et le
commissaire de police se rentre dans
l'âme et entre dans la maison et là
un extraordinaire mystère le commissaire
de police va ressortir avec les quatre
voleurs seulement pour ça il faut une
formule magique que tu vas me donner
immédiatement tout cancon attention
vas-y boum boum badaboum souffre
oui si tu veux oui ça peut marcher comme
ça en effet hop vous avez là le
commissaire de police qui ressort le
voilà le commissaire de police a réussi
à capturer le premier vrai le deuxième
le troisième voleur et le quatrième
volet cette extraordinaire
je ne reviens pas c'est fou hein mr
enfin le même effet qu'en forêt l'autre
jour mais comment fais-tu comment faire
comment fait mais je vous le dis à très
rapidement c'est le tour le plus bête
qui soit regardez comment ça marche vous
prenez bien les quatre valait alors
voilà les 80 les vous les prenez au
départ il n'y a pas de problème mais en
dessous ou horreur vous préparé quatre
autres cartes une n'importe lesquels 2 3
4 vous vous arrangez en retournant les
quatre pour qu'on ne voit que les quatre
valais voilà les quatre vallées mais en
dessous vous avez d'autres cartes
n'est ce pas que personne ne voit et
lorsque vous mettez les quatre vallées
bêtement sur la maison il est évident
que les quatre autres cartes sont au
dessus la preuve ce n'est pas un valet
et vous fait croire que vous placez les
valait 1 2 3 4 n'importe où ça n'a
strictement aucune importance
et lorsque vous mettez le roi évidemment
vous ressortez les quatre valais voilà
ce qu'il fallait faire ce sebha et à sa
manche ça marche à tous les cas sa
manche ayad je marierai d'engins ans si
je pouvais trouver un point commun aussi
astucieux bas du dos formidable il faut
qu'on trouve mes enfants quelque chose
de formidable ou re oui ses côtés alors
dis donc on l'appelle tout de suite
parce qu'on est prêt c'est un oui à
l'époque fabrice un bon tu es au courant
tu es au courant c'est le point commun
oui nous avons on raconte chacun une
petite histoire on est un objet et nous
avons un point commun entre nous je vous
adore quand je commence c'est c'est
assez difficile à expliquer voilà je
suis une entreprise n'est pas une
société une maison commerce une banque
ou un grand magasin
enfin
un endroit où il ya beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent il ya donc beaucoup de
patrons beaucoup de directeur de chef de
service des sous-chefs et puis aussi des
secrétaires des techniciens des livreurs
des représentants des sceaux tessin bon
je sais bien que tout ça est assez
confus mais je te conseille de te
pencher plus particulièrement sur les
personnes qui ont une certaine
responsabilité
voilà qui comprend une certaine
responsabilité j'entrevois va-t-on dire
je alors bâlois qui peut rencontrer dans
les musées dans les galeries de peinture
dans les salons luxueux et même parfois
dans des petites chambres modeste je
suis un tableau peu importe le sujet que
je représente fleurs paysages portraits
peu importe l'époque à laquelle j'ai été
fabriqués en échange premier rang pirro
époque moderne
peu importe également mais dimensions et
peu importe ma valeur du moment qu'il ya
un tableau
je suis là pour tout et bien j'accepte
même d'accompagner une gravure un
dessert une photographie comme ça oui là
je pense que je fais sur la piste mais
j'attends tout même la version 2 pouces
mousson bon bah moi moi moi je suis une
bicyclette mais j'ai fait partie des
plus anciennes de bicyclettes et
j'existerai tant qu on fabriquera des
bicyclettes
vous pouvez en faire de toutes les
tailles toutes les tailles que vous
voulez avec ou sans changement de
vitesse pour les hommes ou pour les
femmes pour les petits ou pour les
grands pour faire le tour de france ou
pour se promener tranquillement je suis
là solide j'ai quelquefois de très
jolies couleurs des jeux peut
malheureusement être tout rouillé amis
je suis un vélo voilà avec ça tu dois
trouver là je pense que vous avez tous
trouvé parce que cette fois ci c'était
plus facile
moi je dirais que vous avez tous en
commun un des cadres
voilà la société a des cadres les
tableaux et les bicyclettes les vélos
ont des cadres bien évidemment on a tous
voila c
ça sera voté a mis la main à la poche et
c'est à moi peut-être oui tout le prêtre
est allé manger va paraître elle à
fabrice et je te prépare quelque chose
de spécial à tout très à la mode à voir
fabrice coudray
oui mais il faut avant de commencer je
vois te demander un petit service me
vois que tu me gratte un peu le coup
j'attends des pouilles 8 ha oui oui oh
mercy mais on how it merci merci
la bourse a la couenne j'ai alors
maintenant on joue d'abord bonjour mais
il est là il est toujours sur le même
genre avait alors 7 a menacé cette amo
en onze lettres
oh non ça c'est trop abc abc sa 7e place
sur potable ou alors vas-y promise aux
lettres alors la première c'est un m
[Musique]
m ou alors tu fais neuf petits traits
voilà très bien
là est la dernière
c'est un sms alors maintenant tu devines
je devine
oui c'est un animal oui à bata trouvé
tout de suite si un animal un groupe pas
très gros nom pas très gros un petit oui
enfin ça dépend des régions des fois il
est petit des fois il est un peu plus
gros tu veux te donne une lettre pour
t'aider
alors où est la troisième la troisième
d'un troisième c'est un l aele oui voilà
voilà
alors évidemment c'est pas facile
c'est un animal qui rampe oui oui oui
oui si on veut oui c'est un animal qu
aurait peut-être beaucoup pâtes oui oui
il a beaucoup de pâtes oui un animal qui
s'appellerait peut-être oui un mille
pattes et bah bravo à 1 qui attaquent
alors comment tu écris mille pattes et
bien comme ça se prononce comme ça se
propage y écoutera ses ébats mi2 l e pm1
i et 2 l europe et à ba2 t2t e e
sss même si c'est un mille pattes est
toujours un ace alors il a mille pattes
alors me barman
oui eh ben tu fais quand même des
progrès a les mêmes yeux tu vois que je
suis enfin cette fois ci ça ressemble
quand même à quelque chose je les envie
le pâtes oui voila j'ai fait j'ai pas
fait de fautes d'orthographe non pour y
acheter brasserait tient un bar mais à
bachy parce que c'est la première fois
un ben oui j'achète absolument et bouby
bon c'est extraordinaire en effet bien
travaillé je fais un baiser parce que tu
sers et vous pousse aussi vivement sa
merci mais on arrive quand vous savez
que je le sais tout mais j'ai envie très
deep et gencives est aussi brillant avec
bel bmc le chansons ah ben oui ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est que je sais tout
je sais tout sur les mille pattes moi je
sais meme qu en angleterre on l'appelle
le sens patin mais c'est encore
exagérément parce que est ce que vous
savez exactement combien ils ont une
pâte en réalité ils en ont 40 2 oui vas
tu es une paire je parle de ceux qu'on
rencontre dans nos régions
tu sais quelquefois en soulevant des
pieds et on en rencontre un épuisant
droit humide
il ya ceux qui vivent dans les pays
chauds évidemment pas mettre beaucoup
beaucoup plus gros et avoir beaucoup
plus de pattes mais cela ils sont
beaucoup plus dangereux voilà c'est bien
mais je t'en remercie parce que je n'ai
pas une passion pour les 1000 par nono
pour toi une belle oui on a ajouté le
belge
la levée du siège mais avec moi c'est
facile la musique tu veux un espace la
famille à 5,2 me saïma ça donnerait pas
la femme n'est pas sain de données mis
seulement salvadore j'ai mes petits fils
cadet s'implante la chanson je te
propose d'y rester pour notre petit j'ai
des bonnes notes tu t'en souviens bien
entendu bon alors nous allons jouer vite
les grandes vedettes
celle qu'on tende talents qui sont si
populaires les vedettes de la chanson tu
les connais bien sûr notre petite reine
nationale au oui ça c'est évidemment
mireille me dérobe oui et puis un que
j'aime beaucoup
comme tout le monde d'ailleurs c'est
cette force de la nature le grand-pont
ma le grand le grand pour marc à
le grand oui pas la marque en pleurant
la main le grand lama
oui tiens pour rester dans les serge
puisqu'il s'agissait de serge lama faut
pas oublier diani jeune gianni adjani
johnny revient yanis et à la manie
l'épée celle pour qui l'école série
lincoln
oui mais c'est fini tu donnes juliette
cette chanson ah ben oui lâche et oui le
bloom
comment lâcher boulot mais oui je sais
plus ce que je raconte ma fait ces
fichiers blum quand même ah oui tu veux
dire celle à elle essaie de faire
tromper mais c'était décide de me faire
tromper si oui j'en suis alors il ya un
groupe de chanteurs aussi que j'aimerais
veut qui est ici celui qu'on commence à
connaître
bien qu'il reste un peu terry un peu
quoi sérieux à mystérieux salariés du
groupe des cas za les plus étranges les
plus volés mux aux bombes alors il
s'agit des quat'zarts miui me c'était
facile alors qui sont ils ces quatre
amis
et à saint brice oui alors là nous
allons mettre un fabrice haiat pouces
moustiques qui vit aux radios tv aura du
oui il y aura du qui vit au ras du sol
au ras du sol mais oui oui il ya tout
quand avec son allié avec son allié avec
son aile et tu sais grands ouverts il
est surpris son âge
on a des dossiers rsa y est missionné y
est y sont noyés façon nay et saulcy
maillet la sunlight ifaw y sont sont des
femmes enfin et ce à quoi va pas et
famille et fado et famille et fado et fa
sol et farré fallait effaré au nom le
plus difficile celui là au nom paraît
trop difficile trop difficile voilà il y
à moi loi qui suit je le sais bien votre
petit à aba à michaux dit à amy ma mère
si oui et nous allons tous les cas vous
montrer ce que nous savons faire sans
avoir lieu près pas mais alors rien près
pas du tout rien préparé n'avons nous
n'avons rien prépa oba préparer
voilà là oui c'est parfait mon petit
fabrice alors là que je trouve que tu as
fait des progrès c'est un essor oh oui
terrible mais qui n'est pas fatigué qui
peut chanter en été je vais chanter mais
ça a été très difficile
oui moi ajouté aussi très très fatiguée
aujourd'hui tu as vu j'ai traduit comme
ça à bafouiller auchan mais oui si tu
veux en avant
les tapis
déjà papa de quatre lits ou l'iran qui
secret que la vie majeur et désiste
léger choc fait des choses mais comme
jenny pas de mine war negro a fait
attention les cavs n'a ni paradis seront
utiles
[Musique]